usted o alguien que conoce pueden que
les hayan diagnosticado triglicéridos
altos este vídeo le mostrará qué son y
cómo se miden sus niveles
los triglicéridos altos pueden tener
efectos dañinos en su cuerpo los
triglicéridos son un tipo de grasa o
lípido que se encuentra en su sangre su
cuerpo usa los triglicéridos para
obtener energía
uno de los lugares de donde provienen
los triglicéridos es su hígado también
provienen de los alimentos que ingiere
los alimentos que pueden elevar sus
triglicéridos incluyen alimentos
grasosos como perros calientes y aceites
tropicales
carbohidratos refinados como papas
fritas
alimentos altos en azúcares simples como
rosquillas y el alcohol
entonces cómo llegan los triglicéridos a
las células que los necesitan los
triglicéridos de los alimentos se
digieren y finalmente llegan a su hígado
en el hígado tanto los triglicéridos de
los alimentos como los creados en el
hígado se combinan con las proteínas
cada una de las moléculas resultantes se
denomina lipoproteína
las lipoproteínas viajan por el cuerpo
en su torrente sanguíneo
llevan triglicéridos a sus células que
los utilizan para producir energía
o si tiene más de lo necesario las
células adiposas almacenan los
triglicéridos como grasa corporal
si usted tiene 20 años o más el national
institutes of health recomienda hacerse
una prueba de sangre cada cinco años
la prueba se llama perfil de
lipoproteína en ayunas
durante esta prueba se le tomará una
muestra de sangre del brazo después que
no haya comido nada entre 9 a 12 horas
está prueba de sangre puede revelarse
sus triglicéridos se encuentran dentro
de un rango saludable
para la mayoría de las personas los
triglicéridos en ayunas deben ser
menores a 150 miligramos por decilitro
500 o más les situaría en un rango muy
alto esto significa que hay demasiada
grasa en su sangre
los triglicéridos muy altos pueden
aumentar el riesgo de pancreatitis y
otros eventos cardiovasculares como
enfermedades cardíacas pregúntele a su
médico cuáles deben ser sus niveles de
triglicéridos
en muchos casos los cambios en el estilo
de vida pueden ayudar a mantener niveles
saludables de triglicéridos estos
cambios incluyen ingerir una dieta baja
en dulces carbohidratos refinados y
alcohol
hacer actividad física y regularmente
controlar su peso
y no fumar
los medicamentos también pueden ayudar a
tratar los niveles alterados de
triglicéridos si su médico les recetó
medicamentos para tratar los
triglicéridos altos es importante que
los tome como se lo indicó e informe
cualquier efecto secundario que pueda
tener